Trump will take the stage later today at
the NRA s annual convention in Dallas
where around 80 thousand members have
gathered the nation's largest gun lobby
group faces increased scrutiny following
the Parkland school shooting
now one Wisconsin student is fighting to
wear shirts with images of guns to
school the high school freshman is suing
his principal for banning him from
wearing those shirts
Nikki Batista is following this story
Nikki good morning good morning Matt
gennaker says his t-shirts reflect his
personal beliefs but after the Parkland
school shooting administrators at his
high school said they were inappropriate
and that he could no longer wear them
it's springtime in central Wisconsin and
15 year old Matt gennaker and his
parents are at the local gun range
shooting is an activity they enjoy as a
family but it's one Matt now says is
being used against him they just said
something like you could be an executor
maybe
the remarks are part of the backlash the
Markuson high school freshman now faces
four wearing these t-shirts one with
pictures of a gun and grenade in school
Matt says he's been wearing the same
shirt since the fall but as parents say
it was only after the Parkland shooting
in February that the school's principal
sent home a letter telling Matt to
change the shirt because it was
inappropriate when Matt refused he was
moved to this cubicle for two days when
he says well your your son's t-shirts
promoting violence
I said his t-shirts celebrate diversity
and I said and then his other t-shirt
says love how is that promoting violence
none of the times was he able to answer
that question in April Matt filed a
lawsuit alleging that there are no
school rules explicitly banning wearing
clothing that depicts firearms and
they're doing so violated his freedom of
expression
John Monroe is his lawyer he's perfectly
within his First Amendment rights to
wear those shirts Monroe is being paid
by Wisconsin carry a pro-gun group again
the issue here isn't really a gun issue
it's a speech issue and yeah you know if
parkland had never happened you were
well I don't think it is it's a it's a
speech issue cases like Matt's are
popping up across the country
in Nevada a middle school student is
suing his school district after it
barred him from wearing these t-shirts
also containing images of guns in a
statement to CBS this morning a school
spokesperson said the child was not
harmed in any way except for being asked
to wear a sweatshirt over his shirt
lawyers and both the Wisconsin and
Nevada case say the schools allowed
students to participate in school
walkout activities supporting gun
control I just think they're hypocrites
you can promote an anti-gun agenda but
then you have a student that comes in
there knows history knows the
Constitution you're gonna tell him he
can't do these lawsuits have merit well
they certainly aren't frivolous Ricky
Kleeman is a CBS News legal analyst this
is a complex issue I think that schools
should have the ability to regulate a
student's clothing for a whole host of
reasons we don't want violence in
schools we don't want gang signs you
don't want people with Nazi swastikas
these things are all obvious that we
would not condone but the mere picture
of a gun is that sufficient while the
lawsuit is pending Matt can still wear
his favorite shirt to school expressing
a belief the shenna curse a is just a
normal part of their lives there are a
lot of people watching that would say
after a school shooting that killed 17
people why not just stop wearing the
shirts for a while because that's just
who Matthew is he's always gone hunting
he's gone target shooting the Second
Amendment thing the Constitution all of
that is part of our family do you
understand the sensitivity around it and
how the school is in a really hard place
I mean I understand I get where they're
coming from but at the same time they're
expecting my son to change who he is
because of what is going on another part
of the country this gennaker say they
are not asking for financial damages in
their lawsuit they just want Matt to be
allowed to wear his shirts in school we
reached out to Marcus an high school and
its attorneys but they declined to
comment I think the times are tough it's
difficult yeah yeah these rules are an
insurmountable pressure to keep kids
safe but now it's upright so it's tough
now thank you very much Nicki
good to have you at the table today